[Music]
my cynical reaction to questions about
consciousness is you tell me what it is
and I tell you if an elephant has it and
that usually shuts people up because you
will not be able to tell me what it is
and how I should measure it that is
really not a good reaction because I
actually believe that animals have some
level of consciousness so for example
the approach that I sometimes take is
that there are certain things that we
humans cannot do without consciousness
if we find these kind of actions also in
other species we must assume that they
also involve consciousness so for
example you cannot plan a party for
tomorrow for your friends without
consciously thinking about how much beer
you need to what kind of music you're
gonna play who's gonna and be invited
that you have to consciously think about
the event before you can plan it now we
have very good evidence that animals can
plan we have lots of experiments now on
it and we have nature observations for
example chimpanzees will collect tools
on one location and then walk for three
miles and so then an hour later they're
going to use these tools to fish for
termites or to open a beehive meaning
that they probably had been planning the
action and we tested out in the
laboratory and we have evidence for
planning and birds we are planning in in
Apes so if they can plan and we plan
consciously
it's very hard to imagine that they can
do these same things that we do
unconsciously I find it hard to imagine
we have other things like thinking back
in time thinking back to events that
happened like a year ago can you do that
we have we have now ways of testing that
it's called episodic memory in animals
and animals have that capacity you
cannot sing back to a specific event in
time like your let's say your wedding or
whatever it is you cannot sing back to a
specific event without consciously
thinking about that and so there are
certain things that animals do and that
we have no evidence for that require in
humans consciousness and and I think
that's a good indicator that the animals
must also have that kind of
consciousness
[Music]